My name is Bailey Arlinghaus and I'm from
Huston Texas.
In 2012 I graduated from Clements High School
in Sugar Land Texas.
Currently I am a Spanish and Political Economy
major at Hillsdale College in Michigan, and
this spring I have the privilege of interning
at the Heritage Foundation.
The Washington Hillsdale Internship Program,
we
call it WHIP for short, we bring anywhere
between ten to twenty students a semester
out to DC.
They take two or three classes and they intern
on the hill, at the Heritage
Foundation, really anywhere they want to.
When we find somebody coming out of college
who has some practical real world experience,
especially experience that applies to what
we do, it really sets them apart.
Washington is one of those places that kids
can learn a lot and gain a lot just from being
hear a few moths.
And in that since, coming here and having
that interning experience I guarantee will
be life changing.